capitaine patrick petit colin bonjour
merci d'être avec nous ce soir
est-ce que vous pouvez nous raconter
vous avez été pendant une semaine aux
feux de forêts notamment du côté
d'artigues
qu'est ce qu'on ressent comment est-ce
qu'on se sent quand on est jamais dire
au milieu de ce brasier dont nous
finalement on voit des images à la télé
c'est quelque chose qui a du mal à
expliquer plus qu'il faut l'avoir vu au
moins est vécu au moins une fois dans sa
vie dans la chaleur le vent le frisson
le bruit mais ça nous a permis de se
retrouver tous ensemble de créer ce
petit groupe qui me permet de me sentir
ces choses-là entre nous c'est difficile
à expliquer j'ai du mal à expliquer
expliquer c'est important d'être
solidaire avec votre collègue du sud oui
très important pour nous ça fait partie
de la première chose là la formation est
ce qu'on est capable de former nos nous
sapeurs-pompiers du département du doubs
donc on a donné trop de collaboration à
me conseiller technique départemental le
capitaine caillou avec qui on est
d'abord tout au long de l'année quelque
chose qui se rapproche de la vérité
puisque jour on veut pas envoyer nos
pompiers sans se rapprocher de ça donc
le oui on met en place une semaine de
stage sur le vif du terrain on dort pas
la nuit ont fait des marches de nuit et
c'est donc très important la formation
pour pouvoir permettre à nos sapeurs
pompiers du doubs pour interpeller
intervenir dans les meilleures
conditions
dans les départements de paca ça c'est
ce que vous apportez au sud mais qu'est
ce que ça vous apporte qu'est ce que ça
apporte à vos hommes de participer à des
actions des opérations comme celle ci
expérience bien sûr forcément ce qu'ils
ont vécu cette semaine la moitié du
personnel
c'était la première fois qu'il
descendait c'est quelque chose qui est
grave et je pense au fond d'eux et qui
permettront de grandir un petit peu dans
de la liste dans l'expérience parce que
l'on peut boire ou feux de forêt si on
n'a pas d'expérience il ya les
sapeurs-pompiers aprilia toute la chaîne
d'encadrement est la chaîne a commencé
des gens qui ont un peu vécu ça moi
j'avais la chance d'être en double
affectation avec les bouches du rhône
qui m'a permis d'apprendre beaucoup et
je remercie les vieux de la vieille dame
un lieutenant du pigiste bonaventure qui
m'ont apporté un petit peu tout leur
savoir pour permettre d'apporter sur
savoir la beaucoup ces techniques est-ce
que du coup forcément on est pompier
dans le doubs on a l'habitude des feux
de maisons des feux d'appartement des
feux ne ferme pas des feux de forêt est
ce qu'il ya une appréhension plus
justement que les collègues du sud
comment on vit ça pour la première fois
ben on a l'habitude de faire nous faut
le faire nous fait d'avortements comme
là bas mais nous le spécialité c'est un
peu fort comme ici qu'on descend là bah
ouais tout le monde sait on sait faire
on sait faire mais arrêter je peux vous
dire que quand on est vraiment dans le
fond et on l'a vécu mercredi soir avec
mon équipe et j'ai une pensée forte je
voulais les remercier parce que ce qu'on
a vécu c'est quelque chose d'un peu
chaud patate comme disait dans le métier
on a vécu quelque chose de chaud donc
ouais ouais c'est important de se
retrouver mais pour rien au monde vous
refuseriez non parce qu'on s'en est
sorti tous ensemble on va y retourner
tous ensemble et j'ai une pensé à mes
collègues et tout le staff qui est
derrière nous qui service médical la
logistique importante pour nous et bat
tous les gens aussi qui nous accueillent
les varois les gens du vaucluse qui nous
apportait à manger à boire avec tant de
choses c'est quelque chose qui nous
reste au coeur merci merci beaucoup